get 25% off a subscription to Babel by
clicking the link below
Babel is an awesome language learning
app they're one of our sponsors I use
Babel to improve my Italian and I'm
loving the results I'd recommend Babel
to anyone go check it out Donald Trump's
ignoramus staffers really need to stop
saying the quiet part out loud for their
own benefit Donald Trump has this total
buffoon of an acting chief of staff
remember there's no permanent chief of
staff right now the acting chief of
staff is Mick Mulvaney we're gonna get
into a lot more of this wacky interview
he gave yesterday to Chris Wallace on
Fox News Sunday later on in the program
but I want to get one clip in front of
you today where Mick Mulvaney has
admitted that Donald Trump despite being
president of the United States which is
a full-time job by the way Donald Trump
still considers himself to be in the
hospitality business as president of the
United States which is effectively an
admission that just like anyone with a
brain suspected Trump is still running
his businesses Trump is still involved
in his businesses despite being
President of the United States
Mulvaney among other incredibly dumb
things that he said yesterday to Chris
Wallace which I'll get to a little bit
later said Trump is still in the
business the context here is that Trump
said he would host the g7 summit at his
own Club Doral then they made the
decision to cancel that because it is
after all a completely unconstitutional
violation of the emoluments clause
here's Mick Mulvaney saying it himself
he is back he's decided that he's not
gonna hold it at Doral he blames that
unquote the hostile media and their
democratic partners but again he was
getting hammered by Republicans so why
did he cave I we talked about it a great
length last night and it's not lost on
me that if we had made decision on
Thursday we wouldn't have had the press
conference on Thursday regarding
regarding everything else that's fine
but we didn't talk about last night and
I honestly think what you saw in the
tweet was real the president isn't one
for holding back his feelings in his
emotions about something he was honestly
surprised at the level of pushback at
the end of the day you know he still
considers himself to be a in the
hospitality business and he saw an
opportunity to take the the biggest
leaders from around the world and he
wanted to put on the absolute best show
the best vis
that he possibly could so then Mulvaney
filibusters a little bit but Chris
Wallace makes the right decision and he
goes back to hold on a second the
President of the United States has
another vocation he considers himself
too wild president still be in the
hospitality industry I just have to pick
up you say he considers himself in the
hospitality business he's the President
of the United States
yeah but he's it that's his background
it's like I'm used to be in the real
estate business I don't know what you
used to do before you were in media if
nothing that's all I've ever done he
wanted to put on a show the right
follow-up there would have been when
Mick Mulvaney says well yeah I mean I
was in real estate before Chris Wallace
should had said okay but now you're the
chief of staff another full-time job of
extraordinary importance to the running
of our government do you still consider
yourself today
to be in the real estate business Chris
Wall is not following up in that way and
we are going to have a lot more about
Mulvaney later on in the program I
believe Mulvaney may be out the door
soon he's going out of his way now to
say total nonsense just to defend Donald
Trump and the thing about that is that
in the short term Trump rewards you when
you express this unhinging unflinching
loyalty to Donald Trump in the short
term where you will go on TV and say
anything no matter how ridiculous to
defend Donald Trump Trump rewards you in
the immediate but then other Republicans
start to cringe the crazy things that
the staffer says become a distraction
they become the subject of news coverage
on corporate media both left right and
center and that's when then Donald Trump
starts to back away and next thing you
know he says he has full confidence in
you and 48 hours later that you're god
you're you end up actually being gone so
this may be the beginning of the end for
Mick Mulvaney and after the break we are
going to get into his full interview
with Chris Wallace where Chris Wallace
does a very good job of pointing out
that Mick Mulvaney is now denying having
said things that are on camera we have
recordings
20:19 technology allows us to go back to
the tape so to speak and look at what it
is that you said so we're going to get
back to that as far as Trump is
currently still in the hospitality
industry the progression usually is no I
never actually said that then Chris
Wallace shows you a clip of you saying
it then it's well I said it but I meant
it as a joke or it wasn't literal then
Trump's Trump comes back and says wait
no hold on I am still in the hospitality
industry and I'm the best at it at which
point Mulvaney has to flip and say oh no
okay yeah I was serious when I said it
and it's actually fine for the president
to both be President of the United
States and still be in the hospitality
industry question to you is this is
Mulvaney saying Trump is still in the
hospitality industry do you think that
this is stupidity or do you think that
they are deliberately trolling at this
point what do you believe is going on
here are they messing with people by
saying absolute and total nonsense like
this or do you think that they are
actually this dumb to say the quiet part
out loud leave a comment if you're
watching on youtube send me a tweet at D
Pakman if you are watching or listening
to the program anywhere else and while
you're on Twitter just a suggestion
follow the David Pakman show at David
Pakman show